[MUSIC PLAYING]
DEBI CABRERA: Data comes
in many shapes and sizes.
In the last videos, we
introduced Apache Beam
and walked through a
batch data processing job.
But how do you handle
processing streaming data?
Let's get into it.
First things first, we need
to define batch processing
and stream processing.
Batch processing uses data
that has a fixed size,
because it represents a data
set that's already completed.
We went through one
example by looking
at all of the words
in Shakespeare's "King
Lear" in the last video.
But it could also be
a much larger data
set, like all the words in
every book in a library.
Once you get your hands
on all of the data,
you can start processing it.
Beam refers to this
type of data as bounded,
because you already have all the
data you'll want to work with.
Stream processing
uses unbounded data,
where you don't have
a complete set of data
because it's still
being updated.
If you think about
a social media feed,
for example, there's constantly
new data being added.
And you may need to process
new events as they come in.
Since the data set
won't ever be complete,
you need to process
events as they stream in
and compute results
on aggregated data.
In order to process
unbounded data,
Beam uses something
called windows.
Let's break down
what windows are.
In Beam, a window generally
represents a range of time.
By default, Beam will
put every piece of data
into the global window,
which represents
the range of time between
negative infinity and infinity.
When you perform any operations
or transforms on your data,
they will apply to
the entire window.
This is what you'll
usually want when working
with a batch processing job.
But what happens when you're
working with an unbounded data
set?
Instead of using the
entire global window,
you can divide elements between
smaller intervals of time.
These windows
represent time ranges,
so you can process
the data in each one.
For example, you could
have 60-minute windows
and count the number of
elements in each window.
The count of each
window would tell you
how many pieces of data were
processed for each hour.
Because each window is
eventually complete,
you can process them
independently and produce
a final answer for that window.
The global window will
contain all the data
as it's being processed.
But that's a pretty
large range of time.
When you define how you want
your data to be windowed,
you can configure
things like how large
the windows are and whether
or not they'll overlap.
Before we dive deeper
into exactly how windows
work though, the
right configuration
depends on how you want
to process your data based
on its timestamp.
But what do we mean
by a timestamp?
Well, if we think
about an event that
happens on a mobile
device, it's easy enough
to grab the time that
the event happened,
according to the device.
We call this event time.
However, that event will also
need to be sent to a system,
like Beam, for processing.
There will always be a
difference between the time
that the event actually
happened and when
the event is processed,
or the processing time.
Especially when you're
receiving events
from multiple devices with
different connectivity
and latency, these
events will almost always
arrive out of order.
If you use processing time
to aggregate your events,
you'll only get an
approximate result at best.
Instead, you'll want
to use the event
time to handle your
data correctly and get
accurate results.
Let's take a look
at an example so we
can see why processing time
won't give you accurate results
and go over how windows work.
Here's a simple example
data set of events
that you might see for
a mobile application.
We can see that
each of these events
is for the same user
ID and each item
represents different user
actions, like tapping
or swiping.
For this data, the
event time property
will represent the actual time
that the event happened and was
collected on the mobile device.
To keep things simple
for this video,
we'll look at the event
time as a number of seconds
rather than showing a
full Unix timestamp.
If we wanted to aggregate and
count the number of events
for this user, it would be a
pretty straightforward count.
We could group the
events by the user ID
and then count them,
which would give us
a total count of five events.
As we mentioned before,
even though we're
looking at these events
ordered by timestamp,
there's no guarantee that
they'll actually arrive
for processing in this order.
Data in a distributed
environment
may be inherently unordered.
And the Apache Beam model
doesn't make any assumptions
about data ordering.
That's why we mentioned
in earlier videos
that peak elections are
immutable and unordered.
OK.
Back to our example data.
We know that there
are some events
and we want to process them.
If we had all of the
events ahead of time,
we could consider
it bounded data
and use a batch processing job.
In reality, we'll often want
to process unbounded data
with the possibility of more
events coming in at any time
and handle events
arriving out of order.
That means we'll need windows.
If we don't configure
anything for windows,
Beam will place all of our
elements in the global window.
If we wanted to get a
count for the events,
we'd have to wait for
the data to be complete.
And since our example
represents unbounded data,
new events could
arrive at any time
and the window will
never be complete.
There is a way to get
speculative results when
working with unbounded
data, but we'll talk more
about that in another video.
In order to get the complete
results we're looking for,
we'll need to subdivide
the data into groups
that we know will eventually
complete using windows.
We'll start by
using fixed windows.
These are the windows of the
same size that repeat, like,
every hour or every 15 seconds.
Using our same data
from before, we
can use fixed windows that
have a size of five seconds.
Using these windows, we
can do a simple aggregation
by counting the data
inside of each window
after the window is complete.
So the first window has
a count of three events
and the second window has
a count of two events.
The right size for
your window depends
on your use case and your data.
But you can specify
the length to Beam
and it takes care of the rest.
Beam can estimate and track
when a window is complete,
which we'll talk about
more later in this video.
However, we did talk about
this being unbounded data.
That means more events
could come in at any time.
And they're not guaranteed
to arrive in the same order
that they happened.
And just like that,
here is a new event.
While this event looks the
same as our other ones,
the event time is
actually at 4 seconds.
So the event itself would've
happened before the events that
happened at 6 and 8 seconds.
Since data like this can
continue to arrive at any time,
Beam needs to determine when
to stop adding new events
and process the data inside
of a window to produce output.
Triggers are the mechanisms
that Beam actually
uses to emit the aggregated
results for each window.
The default afterwatermark
trigger can be overridden.
And there's multiple
types of triggers
that you can customize,
depending on how
you want to process your data.
We'll talk more about those
in the next video too.
When collecting and
grouping data into windows,
Beam uses a watermark to
keep track of how up to date
the events in that window are.
As data flows
through a pipeline,
Beam keeps track of the
oldest event timestamp that it
expects to see at each step.
This is how Beam can
handle and estimate
when a window is
actually complete
and all the data is
expected to have arrived,
which also means Beam can
process the complete window.
Once the watermark for
a window has passed,
the default
afterwatermark trigger
will emit the results
for that window.
Any data that arrives for
that window after this point
is considered late
data, which we'll also
discuss in the next video.
Let's see what this looks
like with our example data.
Since we're trying to illustrate
the differences between event
time and processing
time, we'll take a look
at when these events
actually arrived in Beam.
This is a pretty
optimistic example,
because most of our event
time and processing times
are very close together.
However, the last event
has a bit more delay.
Since we're using
5-second windows,
the data will be split
into two windows.
The tap event at 8
seconds was actually
processed at 9 seconds.
But the overall data would still
be processed in the same way,
since that event is still
part of the same window.
On the other hand,
the final swipe event
has an event time of 4 seconds
but was processed at 9 seconds.
If we were using the
processing time in our windows,
we'd have three
events in each window.
But that doesn't reflect when
the events actually happened.
We would normally want
that new swipe event
in the first window, since
that's actually accurate as
to when the event happened.
So we can see that
using event time
is the right way to
get accurate results.
But Beam still
needs a way to know
when it can expect all the data
in each window to have arrived.
Since out of order data
could arrive at any time,
Beam needs to use a watermark
to estimate when the window is
actually complete.
Let's look at just the
events that would be
contained by our first window.
Because the process
time for the final event
is after the closing
time for the window,
whether or not it makes
it into that window
depends on the watermark.
The delay in reordering
between event arrival
can vary over time.
So the watermark will make
progress at different rates.
If the watermark for
this window hasn't
passed until after the
new event is processed,
then that event will
make it into the window.
Once the watermark
passes, the window
will be processed with
all four events in it.
But if Beam determines that
the watermark has passed
before the new
event is processed,
Beam would close the window
without including the event
and discard it as late data.
This is the default behavior
for handling late data.
And just like most of what we
talked about in this video,
you can customize how
late data is handled.
So to recap what we've
talked about in this video,
there's bounded and
unbounded data sets,
which are aligned with
batch and stream processing.
Beam uses windows
to handle data,
dividing up the
data into segments
so it's easier to work with.
Fixed windows have distinct
starting and ending
times for the data
that goes into them.
Using event time gives
you accurate results
rather than using
processing time.
And Beam uses afterwatermark
as the default
trigger to know when
there is no more data
to be expected in a window.
We'll talk about handling
late data, triggers,
and different kinds of
windows in the next video.
So stay tuned and
thanks for watching.